but recently your Mad Men co-star John
here right at the Independent Spirit
Award yeah yeah okay okay so he looks a
little upset in this picture yeah I'm
really not sure exactly what he what's
happening he looks mad at me I think he
might be holding a grudge we used to
play a lot of games on Mad Men I love
this cat oh yes we used to play a lot of
games what kind of game card games heads
like spades dinner I mean like that kind
of thing like speed speed speed yes oh
we were obsessed with speed and I'm
actually pretty good are you yeah yeah
pretty kind Elizabeth I'm just saying
good so y'all would play all the time
you would we will play games all the
time we would literally work all day
like many many hours per week and then
we would stay quite late and we'd like
to like 2:00 in the morning sometimes
just playing and playing and we'd be
like just one more game just one more
game
and we took it really really seriously
and John and I took it very seriously
now one of us is a sore loser not you
you would be correct
we had a championship and we with speed
and we played oh yeah oh yeah that was a
very serious championship and we played
and we played and we played I did not
lose and we never played again that's
why he's upset that's why I used all his
speed Thunder he loves that
yes five years ago that's amazing no I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this